If you look at the sky after sunset,
and you see something very bright
glowing near the horizon,
and you say:
- Oh my God. What's that?
It's almost certain to be Venus.
It's one of the brightest objects in the sky.
We call it the evening star or the morning star
because it's close to the sun in the solar system.
It tends to follow the Sun,
or precede it, in sunrise.
So the symbol for Venus is
actually a hand mirror,
because Venus was the roman goddess
of love and beauty.
And we see this symbol all over the place,
not just in astronomy, because it's culturally now our symbol for woman,
or for femininity.
And this is counterbalanced by the symbol for Mars,
which people recognize as a symbol for men.
It's a circle with an arrow coming out of it,
and that is representing the shield and the spear,
because Mars was the roman god of war.
So these are the symbols that have come out of astronomy into everyday life, meaning male and female.
It's often called our sister planet,
because it's right next door to Earth.
It's the next planet closest to the Sun.
And it's also almost the same size as Earth,
which is interesting.
And it has an atmosphere,
like Earth does as well.
But it's not a place that
you would want to go on holiday.
Not at all.
Because the atmosphere is actually
almost entirely carbon dioxide.
And so, what we see on Venus is
actually a runaway greenhouse effect.
So, that atmosphere is very good at
trapping the heat from the sun and keeping it there.
So Venus is incredibly hot,
and, in the surface of Venus, the temperatures
are high enough to melt lead.
And, with that, there is an incredible
atmospheric pressure.
So, by standing on the surface of Venus,
you would feel the same amount of pressure
as if you were 800 meters
below the surface of the sea.
Above that
(if that's not enough to put off your holiday plans),
the atmosphere rains sulfuric acid.
So basically it's not a very hospitable place to be.
Even though it's one of the closer planets to us,
it's very unlikely that we're probably going to send human beings there in the year,
or even in the far future.
"Now in an unexplored region of space,
Mariner was placed on its Mercury intercept course by the gravity of Venus."
So it's hard for us to see the surface of Venus,
or it's impossible for us,
because it has this really thick atmosphere.
So we've actually
(we being humanity,
mostly the Americans and the former Soviet Union),
have sent a number of probes to Venus,
all way back from the 60s through the 70s.
Some of those orbited and used radar
to pierce the clouds,
and some of them even managed to land.
Now this was a very difficult piece of
engineering to accomplish,
because the conditions there are so harsh.
And, in fact, the earlier landers
didn't make it very far.
They were crushed by the incredible pressure,
or melted by the temperature.
But some of them did actually make it
down there.
So we do actually have pictures
of the surface of Venus.
"Nasa's Mariner Spacecraft, after traveling
four months and 217 million miles,
began fulfilling its mission as it rendezvous with the planet Venus"
This year, in 2009, is the 400th anniversary of Galileo taking a telescope and pointing it at the heavens.
And one of the things that he observed,
which was very important, was
he managed to observe
the full phases of Venus.
So Venus, like the Moon, undergoes phases,
from our point of view,
because it changes its position relative to the Sun.
And at Galileo's time, we were still working
under this idea of the universe where
the Earth was at the center.
And his observations of Venus undergoing this full spectrum of phases didn't fit in with that picture at all.
And, in fact, that was one of the greatest pieces of evidence that they had that that system was wrong,
and that we had to move our
understanding of the universe,
away from the Earth being the center
towards the sun being the center.
So for me that observation of Venus, it just
goes to show what astronomy does.
Astronomy makes us change the way
we see ourselves, as part of a larger universe,
And simply by taking a telescope, pointing it at the heavens, and seeing something new that didn't fit,
we had to change our entire worldview.